Отже, ми з вами вже багато
чого знаємо з електрики.
Ми знаємо основні електричні величини
і ми навіть знаємо один з
законів постійного струму.
Це закон Ома.
Сьогодні ми спробуємо з
вами порозв’язувати задачі,
бо практичне застосування знань,
які ви набуваєте, дуже важливе.
Отже, давайте ми пригадаємо
спочатку формули, які ви знаєте.
Це, по-перше, формула закону Ома.
Я її напишу зараз на дошці.
Сила струму дорівнює відношенню
електричної напруги до опору провідника.
Сила струму на ділянці кола є пропорційною
до напруги на кінцях цієї ділянки
і обернено-пропорційна до
опору цієї ділянки. Це – закон Ома.
Ми знаємо з вами ще одну формулу
опору металевого провідника.
І знаємо, що залежить опір металевого
провідника від його лінійних розмірів –
довжини та площі поперечного перерізу.
Та ще від характеристики
самого провідника.
Якщо ми з вами з цієї формули закону Ома
виведемо формулу опору
провідника, то у нас буде такий запис.
Ми маємо напругу поділити на силу струму.
Давайте подивимося на цю формулу.
Опір залежить, нібито, математично
від електричної напруги і від сили струму.
Чи це дійсно так?
Чи є опір металевого провідничка
залежним від напруги і сили струму?
Ми з вами домовлялися, що опір –
це є характеристика самого провідника
і залежить тільки від його параметрів,
тільки від його лінійних розмірів,
і характеристик самого
провідника, тобто кристалічної гратки.
Тобто це – просто математичний
вираз, а фізичного сенсу він не має.
Опір самого провідничка не залежить
ані від напруги на його
кінцях, ані від сили струму.
Це сила струму є залежною величиною.
Отже, в цьому ми розібралися з вами.
А тепер, ми говорили з вами,
що прилади вимірювальні -
амперметр, який вимірює силу струму
і вольтметр – вони
по-різному підключаються.
Дивіться, візуально вони дуже схожі,
тільки тут стоїть буквочка
А, а тут буквочка V.
Чи можна їх міняти місцями при включенні?
Про це ми поговоримо пізніше трішечки.
А зараз ми маємо поговорити, який же опір
у амперметра і який опір у вольтметра,
і чому так важливо їх
підключати саме так, як потрібно -
амперметр послідовно, а вольтметр
паралельно до ділянки кола.
Отже, амперметр, ми домовлялися з вами,
аж ніяк не має впливати на
протікання струму по електричному колу.
Він тільки слідкує, він є лічильником.
Отже, без перешкод має електричний струм
протекти по тому провідничку,
який має амперметр.
Тому, як ви вважаєте, яким має
бути електричний опір амперметра?
Чи має він перешкоджати? Ні.
Отже, електричний опір
амперметра дуже маленький.
Я навіть так напишу, що він
майже дорівнює нулю. Майже.
Але нічого не буває ідеальним.
Це для ідеального
амперметра ми можемо сказати,
що він дорівнює нулю,
але такого в житті не буває.
А яким же має бути опір вольтметра,
який підключається
паралельно до ділянки кола?
Струм має протікати саме по колу
і вольтметр не має заважати і на
себе брати якусь частину енергії.
Тому електричний опір вольтметра,
він, ми скажемо, є таке математичне
позначення, безкінечність.
Він дуже-дуже великий.
Він навіть безкінечний для
нашого кола, для нашої ділянки кола.
Отже, маленький опір у амперметра
і дуже великий опір у вольтметра.
Це ми з вами зафіксували і це ми знаємо.
Так, добре. А потім більш детально,
пізніше, про це ще поговоримо –
що буде відбуватися, якщо
поміняти раптом місцями.
Таке буває, іде лабораторна робота.
І учні іноді плутають ось два
прилади, і міняють їх місцями,
вмикаючи вольтметр послідовно і
амперметр паралельно до діляночки кола.
Ви поки що подумайте – що може
відбутися, якщо там включити?
А потім пізніше про це поговоримо.
Отже, сьогодні у нас з вами
буде декілька задач і на закон Ома,
і на опір металевого провідничка.
І давайте подивимось першу задачу.
Вона буде такою.
У нас є графік, ми з вами
вміємо працювати з графіком.
Пам’ятаємо, що графік
залежності сили струму від напруги
називається вольт-амперною
характеристикою.
Подивіться, нам поданий графік
залежності сили струму від напруги.
Нам потрібно за цими даними.
Які представлені у графіку,
визначити опір цього провідничка, через
який пропускається електричний струм.
Як же це зробити?
Дивіться, у нас є клітиночки
і ними зручно користуватися,
бо ми маємо взяти якусь
певну електричну напругу
і відповідне їй значення
електричного струму, сили струму.
І користуючись формулою закону Ома,
ми маємо поділити одну величину на іншу.
Головне – не переплутати.
Дуже зручно брати ось таку
точечку, де пряма наша проходить
через перетинання ось цих кліточок.
Яку ще точечку зручно взяти?
Ось цю останню точечку і ось цю.
В будь якому разі у нас лінійна залежність
і у нас має вийти одне значення.
Давайте ми з вами,
тут є у нас відповіді вже.
Давайте поки що я буду
обводити нашу формулу,
якою ми будемо користуватися, в рамочку,
а ви спробуйте поділити вірно.
Яка ж відповідь у вас вийде?
Ось наша формула закону Ома.
Ось наша робоча формула, за
якою ми будемо визначати наш опір.
Давайте ми візьмемо
будь-яку, ось таку давайте.
Тут у нас 30 вольт напруга,
і відповідає їй 2 ампери сила струму.
Давайте ми напишемо з вами ці дані.
Напруга електрична,
вона дорівнює 30 вольтам,
сила струму дорівнює 2 амперам.
Нам невідома величина
за ім’ям «електричний опір».
Ось цю формулку я пишу сюди.
Напругу ми маємо поділити на силу струму.
І підставляю значення.
30 вольт я ділю на 2 ампери і у
мене виходить 15, дистанцюю, Ом.
Відповідь: 15 Ом.
А тепер давайте подивимося, а
якщо б ми взяли з вами ось ці точечки:
15 вольт я ділю на 1 ампер
– у мене виходить 15 Ом.
Якщо ми візьмемо з вами напругу 45
вольт, ви бачите – це остання точечка,
і поділимо її на 3 ампери,
то у нас теж вийде 15 вольт.
Отже, іноді бувають графічні задачі
і дані треба брати саме з графіка.
Сподіваюся ви зрозуміли як
працювати за графічними задачами.
А тепер давайте
подивимося наступну задачу.
Ця задача на закон Ома.
Подивіться, будь ласка:
який опір має вольтметр,
розрахований на 150 вольт,
якщо сила струму в ньому не
повинна перевищувати 10 міліампер?
Буквочка м – це міліампер.
Отже, напруга дорівнює 150 В
і сила струму 10 мА.
Нам треба дізнатися
опір цього провідничка.
Що ми маємо зробити?
По-перше, дивимося на колоночку CІ.
На одиниці вимірювання і
переводимо в систему СІ.
Ми пам’ятаємо, я ось тут навіть
напишу, що це у нас система СІ.
Ми пам’ятаємо, що «мілі»
в тисячу разів менше.
Я ділю на тисячу, отже, свою
кому переношу на три знаки вліво.
1, 2, 3. І пишу, що це буде 0,01 А.
А тепер наша формула -
основна формула закону Ома,
ось вона – і наша формула робоча.
Ми маємо напругу поділити на силу струму.
Я підставляю всі значення
і подивимося, що виходить.
Поділю на 0,01 А.
Ми знаємо з вами, що для того,
щоб поділити на 0,01 якесь число –
це те ж саме, що помножити на 100.
Отже, ми множимо це число 150 на 100
і у нас виходить 150, я так і
пишу, і ще додаю два нулики.
Ось стільки у нас буде Ом.
Давайте ми таке велике
число переведемо... в скільки?
В яке, які одиниці вимірювання?
Ось тут напрошується три нулики,
щоб ми перевели в кіло Оми,
бо префікс «кіло», ми
пам’ятаємо – це тисяча.
Отже, у нас виходить 15
кОм. Це – відповідь цієї задачі.
Відповідь. Яка ж у нас відповідь?
Це у нас не просто
провідничок, це – вольтметр.
У вольтметра, ми з вами
сказали, дуже великий опір.
15 кОм – це опір нашого вольтметра.
Таким чином ми з вами переконалися,
що у вольтметра дуже великий опір і
він не пропускає (це як забруднена труба),
він не пропускає майже
через себе електричний струм.
Цю задачу ми розв’язали з вами.
Отже, задача наступна:
До кінців мідного й
алюмінієвого провідників
однакових розмірів
прикладено однакові напруги.
Чи однаковими є сили струму в них?
Подивіться, будь ласка.
У мене два провіднички
однакових розмірів.
Ми спочатку підключаємо один провідничок,
міряємо силу струму,
який проходить по ньому.
Потім його прибираємо,
включаємо інший провідничок
і дивимося, яка сила струму
проходить по іншому провідничку.
Скажіть будь ласка, якщо
у них однакові розміри –
це і довжина, і площа поперечного
перерізу – чим вони відрізняються?
Різні метали, різні кристалічні гратки,
різні характеристики самого провідничка.
Як можна порівняти силу струму?
Де ж вона буде більше,
де ж вона буде менше?
Або вона будуть однаковими?
Дивіться. В кожному
збірнику задач з фізики
обов’язково наприкінці
збірника є довідкові матеріали.
На попередньому уроці
ми з вами показували
фрагмент таблиці електричних
властивостей речовин.
А тепер ми з вами скажемо,
що треба подивитися в довідник.
Або в збірнику, або в
підручнику є така табличка.
Ось вона. А ось ця формулка
нам зараз знадобиться.
Дивіться: однакові довжини,
однакові площі поперечного перерізу.
Залишилося порівняти питомий опір.
Отже, питомий опір алюмінію я пишу.
Ро алюмінію = 0,028 Ом на мм квадратний,
вважаємо, що вони
тонкі, поділений на метр.
Так, і у нас ще один провідничок таких
же розмірів – це мідь, мідний провідничок.
Дивимося. Мідь 0,0017 Ом на
мм квадратний і поділений на метр.
Ну давайте тепер логічно
з вами обговорювати.
Ми знаємо з вами, що
чим більший є питомий опір
певної речовини/певного металу,
тим опір цього провідничка теж
буде більший, пряма залежність.
Питомий опір алюмінію
більший, ніж питомий опір міді,
тому можемо зробити висновок,
що опір алюмінієвого провідничка
таких самих розмірів буде більшим,
ніж опір мідного провідничка
таких самих розмірів.
Отже, я пишу, що R
алюмінієвого провідничка
є більшим, ніж R мідного провідничка.
Ми з вами відповіли на питання задачі.
Отже, якщо розміри провідничків однакові,
а треба, щоб струм був менший,
проходив по даному колу менший,
то ми маємо включити сюди
якийсь резистор з більшим опором,
щоб струм протікав менший.
Так, таку задачу ми теж розв’язали.
Ну а тепер задача інша.
У нас є такий провідничок мідний.
Тут нам неважливо з чого він
зроблений - важливо, що він є.
Ми його навпіл складаємо
і навіть скручуємо.
Я не буду дуже сильно цього робити.
Ми уявляємо, що я його скрутила. Скажіть,
будь ласка, чи зміниться його опір?
Давайте подивимося, що ж змінилося?
Змінилася, по-перше, його
довжина. Вона зменшилася у два рази.
Якщо ми його скрутили, то ми
вже маємо інший провідничок,
у якого площа поперечного
перерізу теж змінилася.
Вона збільшилась або зменшилась?
Дивіться: цей другий
провідничок, він став товщим,
тобто площа поперечного
перерізу збільшилася в два рази.
Давайте аналізувати, тепер математично.
Я витираю ось цю
задачу і ми пишемо з вами,
давайте, нехай у нас буде: R1, l1, S1.
Давайте ми напишемо з
вами, що l2 = l1 поділити на 2.
Давайте ми напишемо, що S2 дорівнює 2S1.
Перевіряємо, чи вірно я написала.
Була у нас якась довжина.
Ми її зменшили вдвічі.
Отже, довжина другого провідничка
в 2 рази менше, написали вірно.
Була якась площа поперечного перерізу.
Ми перекрутили цей провід і
площа поперечного перерізу
отриманого дротика стала в 2 рази більше.
А тепер ми хочемо дізнатися, а
чи будуть відрізнятися їх опори?
Давайте ми так напишемо дробом: R1 до R2,
відношення візьмемо ось таких двох величин
і будемо аналізувати.
Я пишу сюди першу цю
формулу. Просто переписую:
l1 на S1. Я пишу другу
формулу: Ро на l2 і на S2.
А тепер ми будемо з вами
ділити один дріб на інший дріб.
Пішла вже математика. Ну
давайте спробуємо таке зробити.
R1 на R2 поділене, тобто
поділили ліві частини,
а тепер спробуємо поділити праві частини.
Не роблячи, при цьому,
триповерховий дріб.
Ми пригадуємо, що для того,
щоб поділити дріб на дріб,
треба перший дріб помножити
на перегорнутий другий.
Давайте так і зробимо. Я під
одну рисочку підводжу, я пишу Ро,
бо у нас не змінився матеріал,
речовина. Ро на l1 поділити на S1.
Я написала зараз
вираження для першого опору.
На що я маю поділити? На
перегорнутий ось цей дріб.
Тобто S2 у мене піде
вже чисельник. Я пишу S2.
Далі, а Ро на l2 піде у знаменник.
Поки що я бачу, що можу скоротити на Ро.
Ну давайте хоч якось спростимо цей дріб.
А тепер що ми можемо
зробити? У нас є деякі дані.
Давайте ми напишемо,
тепер зробимо заміну.
Замість, так я пишу l1,
замість S2, я напишу 2S1, так.
А тепер я пишу S1 не
заміняючи його і замість l2
я маю написати l1 поділене на 2.
Я можу написати ось так,
дивіться, l1 поділене на 2.
Про яке ми тільки що з вами домовлялися,
що триповерхового дробу у нас не буде.
Я залишаю l1 ось тут в знаменнику.
А куди піде двієчка? А
двієчка піде вже на гору.
А двієчка піде вже в
чисельник. Тому я дозволю собі,
ну давайте я так і залишу, щоб у
нас був такий логічний ланцюжок.
Я напишу тепер l1 на 2S1,
поки що нічого не скорочую.
На S1 теж ділю. l1 залишаю,
двієчку я пишу чисельник.
Я перевела її, перенесла її в чисельник.
Тепер давайте скорочувати
S1 скоротили, l1 скоротили.
Що у нас виходить? У нас виходить,
що – я перепишу це відношення –
що відношення R1 до R2 дорівнює 4. Що це
означає? Може це не інформативний запис.
А давайте ми інакше напишемо. Ми
напишемо, що R2 = R1 поділити на 4.
Це той же самий дріб, тільки
переписаний у іншому вигляді.
Тобто що сталося з
опором? Опір зменшився.
В скільки разів? В 4 рази зменшився опір.
А тепер давайте подивимося з
точки зору фізики цього процесу.
Дивіться. Став наш провідничок
коротший, так? І вже опір зменшився.
Просто логіку тепер вмикаємо.
Опір зменшився в 2 рази.
Наша площа поперечного
перерізу збільшилася в 2 рази.
Тобто 2 сюди і ще одна 2 ось тут, за
рахунок того, що воно збільшилося.
І ми маємо, що чим менший і товщий
провідничок, тим опір його буде менший.
Ми це довели. В цій
задачі відповідь така:
що, якщо навпіл зігнути провідничок,
то його опір стане в 4 рази менший.
Ось така відповідь в нашій задачі.
Добре, така задача у нас є.
Сподіваюся, ви зрозуміли чому і
як ми прийшли до такої відповіді.
Отже, якщо ми з вами
оберемо вірну відповідь,
то це буде відповідь б)
– зменшиться в 4 рази.
Ну і давайте ми з вами
ще одну задачу розв’яжемо,
таку, де ми ось ці дві формулки закону
Ома і опору металевого провідника
поєднаємо в одній задачі. Дивіться:
ось в мене два таких прилади.
Це – такий кип’ятильничок,
можна його занурювати у воду,
вмикати нашу розетку, де там
напруга 220 вольт і вода буде закипати.
Ось це наша пічечка, дивіться.
Зараз такими пічками
майже не користуються,
проте колись вони були таки популярні і
вони були на кухні у будь-якої господарки.
Був такий час.
Ось тут такий, дивіться,
керамічний лабіринт прокладений.
І в ньому дуже ретельно прокладена
така спіралечка. Ось так вона іде.
Чому спіралька? Чому іноді провіднички
намотують і роблять з них такі спіральки?
Щоб зменшити габарити.
Ось тут має бути великий опір
для того, щоб нагрівалася ця пічка
і перетворювалася
електрична енергія на теплову.
І тут, і тут перетворюється
Ми на попередньому уроці говорили з вами
про такий прилад, який
називається реостат.
Там теж було щільно
навито такий провідничок.
Іноді треба знати – а яку ж
довжину провідника треба взяти
для того, щоб працював кип’ятильник,
працювала електрична пічка,
щоб реостат мав певний опір і можна
його було вмикати в електричне коло.
Отже, спочатку все прораховують,
а потім вже купляють певну довжину
провідничка і його використовують.
Давайте ми розв’яжемо таку задачу з вами.
Сила струму спіралі
електрокип’ятильника 4 А.
Пишу 4 А сила струму.
Кип’ятильник
увімкнено в мережу з напругою 220 В,
так як ми і говорили
з вами. Напруга 220 В.
Так, якою є довжина ніхромового дроту, з
якого виготовлено спіраль кип’ятильника,
якщо площа його
перерізу 0,1 квадратних мм.
Такий, тоненький провідничок.
І нам вже вказано, щоб ми не
шукали, питомий опір ніхрому.
Він великий. 1,1 Ом на мм
квадратний і поділений на метр.
Що ж нам треба знайти?
А треба нам знайти – а яку ж довжину
ми повинні взяти цього провідничка,
щоб у нас був такий гарний кип’ятильник?
Дивимося, чи треба щось переводити?
Ні, не треба. Навіть
ті міліметри квадратні
ми зберігаємо, тому що у нас питомий
опір має таку одиницю вимірювання.
Давайте подивимося, до якої
формули входить довжина?
До формули опору металевого провідничка.
Я пишу цю формулу, вона основна.
R = Ро помножити на l поділити на S.
І ми домовлялися позбавлятися знаменника,
домножуючи ліву і праву
частину на цей знаменник.
Я переписую, що RS = Ро l.
І тоді нам простіше вже
вивести з цього рівняння довжину.
Я маю ліву частину,
тобто RS поділити на Ро.
Ось так ми визначимо нашу довжину.
Дивимося, чи все у
нас є? У нас нема опору.
У нас є площа поперечного перерізу
і у нас є питомий опір провідничка.
Звідки нам взяти наш опір? А
ми знаємо формулу закону Ома.
Пишу основну формулу. Ось ми знаємо,
що з цієї формули ми вивели ось цю.
Формула закону Ома, я
написала її, вона основна.
З неї я вивожу наш
опір. R = U поділити на I.
Отже, ця задача в дві
дії. Перша дія і друга дія.
Чи можна звести цю задачу до однієї дії?
Можна, підставивши замість
опору цю праву частину.
Давайте ми з вами зробимо в
2 дії, щоб нам було зрозуміліше.
Ми порахуємо опір провідничка,
220 В поділити на 4 А.
Відповідь буде в Омах. 22 я ділю
на 4 по 5 і ще 20 на 4 = 55 Омів
має цей провідничок, такий опір.
Ну і нам залишилося тепер
відповісти на питання задачі.
l = 55 Ом, я множу на 0,1 мм квадратних
і ділю – на скільки я ділю,
на що я маю поділити? На ро,
а ро у мене 1,1 Ом на мм
квадратний поділити на метр.
Отже, скорочуємо одиниці вимірювання.
Мм квадратний, мм квадратний. Ом і Ом.
Залишаються метри, знаменник, знаменник,
перегортаємо і будуть у нас просто метри.
Кому і кому прибираю на 10 множу
чисельник і знаменник, ви бачите.
І 55 ділю на 11. Отримую 5
і знаю, що у нас метри підуть в
чисельник і це наша відповідь.
Ми маємо взяти п’ять метрів
ніхромового провідничка
для того, щоб отримати кип’ятильник,
щоб по ньому міг протікати струм 4 А.
А вмикати ми маємо просто в нашу
розетку, яка дає нам напругу 220 В.
Ось таку задачу ми з вами розібрали.
Сьогодні ми з вами
розібрали декілька задач.
Це були задачі і якісні, там де ми
задавали питання, відповідали на них
і обґрунтовували нашу відповідь. Ми
розв’язали з вами розрахункові задачі,
застосовуючи формули закону Ома і
формулу опору металевого провідничка.
Я єдине, що хочу вам
додати, що іноді буває таке,
що не площа поперечного перерізу
дається, а діаметр провідничка.
а діаметр провідничка. І ми маємо з
математики пригадати таку формулу,
що площа кола дорівнює Пі r в квадраті,
або вона дорівнює Пі D
в квадраті поділене на 4.
Що таке r? Це радіус.
Що таке D? Це діаметр,
який в 2 рази більший, ніж радіус.
Що таке Пі? Ми пам’ятаємо
– це, приблизно, 3,14.
Це площа кола. А ми знаємо, що у
нас провідничок в перерізі – це коло.
Отже, сьогодні ми розв’язували задачі,
сьогодні ми застосовували наші знання
і набували навичок у розв’язку
задач. Я вам дякую за урок.
До побачення!